m
une ambulance
week-end
un free agent
je veux dire par là
avez vous trouvé votre nature moi c'est
ici dans votre région que je pense que
les couverts la mine enfants que j'ai eu
la chance de passer beaucoup de temps
dans les alpages grimpé de montagne le
promener en famille ont été accueillis
chez nos bambins aujourd'hui à 50 ans
j'ai roulé ma bosse sont différents
continents et je pense qu'en fait la vie
est une quête une quête de sens
je m'en rends compte que bien se
connaître permet de mieux connaître
l'autre est bien là se connaissent se
posaient des questions
les duels regardons un ciel étoilé
tam est devenue des cours et le monde
c'est celle qui va sans doute conduit il
ya dix ans maintenant apprendre mes
valises et m'installer avec ma famille
et 18 h en mairie
shanghai si différents à chaque ces
choses des racines et ce fut malgré tout
une expérience extraordinaire sur le
plan personnel le plan familial sur le
plan offensif si sorti de sa zone de
confort vous fait bander choix de gagner
à m chacun des enfants aussi de rire
mais il y avait eu ou à l'intérieur de
moi y avait quelque chose à payer je
cherchais ce qu'est cet axe vertical qui
vous pousse à vous plaisent découvrez
votre sphère de sens et vous interrogez
ça me manquait bien sûr les vidéos mais
il ya une masse nature et en fait je
n'ai rien inventé il ya 2500 ans
socrates a les connais toi toi même tu
découvres à l'euro et les nuls
c'est fantastique on a réinventé ses
dires pris le pli
le problème aujourd'hui c'est quelque
part le monde est plate
on est d'accélérer on est interconnecté
on est hyper comme éviter tout va vite
la vie avance et on accuse cette taxe il
n'y a plus pour time pour protéger ne se
disent pas seulement un tout est
simultané et en fait moi je crois que
contradictions structurelles entre
besoin de verticalité que quelque part
on a tous je découvrais en huit ans et
demi de mes amis et de ma famille on a
sept et deux sens et vous allez vite et
seconde horizontal dans lequel on évolue
on l origine de quitter crise que nous
traversons aujourd'hui le monde est plat
je ne vais pas vous faire l'affront de
vous détailler toutes les crises que
nous traversons les médias s'en occupe
très bien vous regarde le journal ce
soit ou non jacou de la chine une chose
crise en chinois huawei j7 danger et
opportunité je suis avant tout
entrepreneur et l'ombre opportunités
safetic suis opportuniste un
entrepreneur est reparti ici
est il réaliste il veut rester en vie
entre nous et donc pense que si on y
regarde bien on a parlé l'innovation on
a parlé tabou est en fait il ya un monde
qui parle est un monde qui n'est je
pense qu'on est en pleine renaissance
et si vous regardez l'histoire chaque
révolution des modes de communication du
2 mai à 5 cibles a entraîné une
renaissance internet aujourd'hui entrer
une renaissance
nous vivons dans bay sands a stick qui
est plein d'opportunités
il est évident que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse
alors conquis sucer le minerai avec la
chine 10 est une chose
nous avons deux lignes et la seconde
commence on réalise qu'on en a cure
on a quitté la chine et c'est moi je
crois que j'en suis là lance il est
d'avis qu'on a je suis là où je réalise
de jean ribul et en héritage
je me suis posé la question de savoir ce
que je vais en faire
l'héritage c'est quoi l'argent c'est ce
que nous a appris à 3 kg héritage
d'incohérences et donc j'ai très vite
cherché des activités entre patients
sens et longuement si j'en avais et j'ai
décidé de réorienter ma vie alors je
vais vous raconter une petite histoire
et c'est amusant parce que c'est une
histoire de famille où la loi est en
fait j'ai appris aujourd'hui il ya
quelques années
c'est une histoire de célèbres bandes
qui taisent je vous explique alice mon
cousin lui la vie porte et qui j'ai
d'emballer il rappeler les montagnes du
valais c'est fantastique et qui un jour
en rendant les peaux de phoque casse une
fixation dans ce magnifique village de
cobain et se rencontrent l'endroit est
si celui là que 2 500 ans exposé le sud
mais 500 m d'altitude un village élisant
40 applications par habitation 40
construction dix habitations 100
personnes après la guerre des
constructions en bois les granges
fantastique extraordinaire sublime 13
mai l'exode rural a fait son travail
il reste dix habitants il ya dix ans et
ludovic ainsi cheminé seul il y a
quelque chose à faire
le patrimoine de la suissesse à une
grande partie des suisses est simple et
se maquille one est en train de
disparaître
et alors il appelle son cousin chinois
qui ne sait pas où il met les pieds et
enlèvements dans deux sites
renseignements le chinois byd venir et
il est parti il est parti dans une
aventure qui est une longue aventure et
les gens viennent à mon introduction on
se compte la question que 80 alors elles
ont fait la voie normale ou à londres
perd la face heures en hiver m
allons-nous faire de la promotion
immobilière acheter rénover vendre et
s'en aller où allons nous partager cette
passion ce sens et puis rien toute cette
réflexion de ce lille le monde a besoin
d'endroits de paix l'endroit de nature
d'endroits de silence c'est ça le luxe
ultime
le monde a besoin de cette verticalité
ce village antastique pour débloquer
quelque chose la décision est prise
nous allons partager des patients toutes
ces aventures nous allons connu enfant
dans les montagnes avec le plus grand
monde
qu'est-ce qu'on va le faire afin de
faire vivre et donner de l'ampleur à
toutes les personnes les acteurs du
changement qui vont vivre dans ce
village est venu y séjourner on s'est
dit on doit en france et la cohérence
dans un concept architectural cohérente
qui préserve le patrimoine tunis médias
intègre l'innovation
oui bravo après tradition innovation
confort et nature ont traduit à travers
des endroits moins d'heures mais à
travers l'alimentation en ayant relancé
des cultures landreau et n'avait plus
depuis 50 ans
alimenter notre et ce tant à travers
l'état l'activité on décide de devenir
la résonance de la cohérence au séjour
des gens qui vivent là trouver un amant
vous ne paie aujourd'hui il me semble
que le luxe ultime et qui est rare
c'est quoi c'est là moi je les dis
savoir du temps du silence
la beauté de la nature
christine étape et l'authenticité ont
les dents avant nomme plein est pareil
partout il faut préserver ce match c'est
important
je vais conclure en quelques nous je
crois que 21,6 au niveau individuel
s'est caractérisée par le je pense donc
je suis tout était soit prouvé tout
l'été scientifique
tout est matérialiste au sens
philosophique du thème ce qui n'est pas
prouvé est suspect et on a négligé
niveau individuel nos émotions avant les
émotions les et viger docker et sans
doute négligé ou cachemire
cette quête de sens au 21ème sic mal
vous l'aviez en rhônes badini massif
sera spirituel
je crois qu'on assiste à un
rééquilibrage on se réapproprie dans que
on parle de deux émotions et on ose
parler du sens qu'on peut donner à notre
vie nos actions au niveau collectif
si les modèles économiques consistait à
il en crée de la valeur pour
l'actionnaire et d'un autre côté et
satisfaire les clients parce qu'il faut
pouvoir maximiser la création de son
action
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le son se rendre
au coeur de l'action entrepreneurs et m
de l'action de toute organisation qu'ils
soient faux profiteurs tons pâles propos
pas le profit sans but lucratif
je crois que le son c'est un modèle
avoué mais pas dans le sens un modèle
pour préserver l'environnement
le sens est un modèle pour ménager et
communautés dans lesquelles votre
entreprise a un impact et je pense que
c'est en innovant en remettant
simplement dix ans dans toutes nos
activités humaines concret va le monde
de demain et ce monde de demain en fait
il s'agit simplement de reprendre le
temps de retrouver sa na qu on est tous
uniques
on a tous un sens et ce sens on peut le
mettre aux services par l'innovation de
nos actions dans la vie de tous les
jours et crédit pour nos enfants un
monde meilleur pour moi c'est ça la
liberté c'est ce choix d'agir en
conscience
merci